siamo in stazione per non partire le 9
23 per andare io milano e ragazzi a roma
ma trent tutti quanti i tre miss al
momento cancellati perchè nel disastro
non ho idea di come faremo che ritardano
arrivi facci vedere come i saldi facci
vedere un binario due torri scusate sto
facendo fornita renato stabile
sì
signori miei oggi va così ci troviamo ai
musei vaticani san pietro da dietro
questo perché un po di cultura fa sempre
bene
tornati a sanremo si presentano nuovi
problemi il primo è che stasera c'è la
festa del liceo harry potter e non so di
mettermi che stiamo cercando un qualcosa
da farmi indossare che sia tematico lui
ha già la maschera perché io no in
quante procura recenti fatti grazie ma
la nostra più banali volevo qualcosa in
che centrico ragazzi ecco noi abbiamo
finito di girare purtroppo non abbiamo
potuto riprendere determinate cose
perché non si poteva però bellissimo qui
è venuta un'idea aiutati anche dalla mia
amica valentina anche gli appetiti che
cinesi che abbiamo trovato tutto
valentina la nostra fenice il soffitto
con le età no però non devi far vedere
niente e dei fatti pop
vai fa il verso della giovane felice
esatto poi fai tipo una specie di morte
della fenice e poi lega e poi tutto di
colpo si fi e togli nome 13 mentre ti
giri e di enti fenice ottimo non devi
capire questo e per il mio ruolo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi sono anziana penserete che un pollice
questa asta gruppo scusate se il nostro
boccino d'oro è un po soffitta di hr dei
vicini
o no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
devi togliere la la ram falconara
raggiungiamo la rana giriamo
allora ragazzi oggi sono un po di giorni
dove compleanno di alice perdonatemi se
vi ho fatto vedere solamente roba presa
da stories anche se meno ripromesso di
far vedere la maestra che stava
veramente veramente è stata pensata al
millimetro
non ho tirato fuori il telefono mai mai
ti chiedo scusa a walter tirar fuori il
cellulare e premere reca una cosa che mi
devo porre ricordare a tipo oggi siamo
già san valentino e sto cercando di fare
una cosa paulina rubio spirito dei fiori
al lavoro e adesso devo andare alla
ricerca di un posto dove mangiare
stasera orientarli anche un'altra
sorpresa tv un regalino ma non riesco a
trovare in calo è tornato a casa e gli
ho appena fatto vedere anche un regalo
che gli ho preso che gli piace e molto
da meno anzi mi ha fatto anche lui e dei
regalini molto carini questa cosa
fichissima questo pegaso questo gli
unicorno e si monta da mettere tipo sui
mobili e compagnia bella cosa stupenda
che era all'interno di questa carta e la
stessa foto nostra stupenda spilla di
sguardo da mettere su cappotti maglioni
e cose così
e infine una sciarpa della moda una
sciarpa dello stile che forse in merito
niente questo qui è tutto e dopo ti
porterò mangiare in un posto speciale
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi guardate dove tomio di malo
sharmila tutti quanto sta facendo la
coda alla vaccinara giuditta nostra
bardi boss delle torte dei compratori
applicate in quota non la vediamo se
stai fare meglio di early e niente
adesso li rivedremo di nuovo il set per
lo shopping ovviamente siamo andati in
un ristorante che sono preoccupato e
siamo scappati in cassa volete mangiare
romano contento che grazie miglioramento
volevo dire una cosa ne ha tanto a
jamali di ci sentiamo di là mangiare
questo enrico che mangia qui a dire che
quello stesso sonno assoluto art ecco lo
faccio finita male avuto bisogno di
tutti questi rimaniamo io più o meno
posso mangiare per le nomadi che ogni
giorno ancora tale fatto cioè nei
biscotti e la tua sul magna di preghiera
per colpa tua e succedono messo guarda
ai fatti mangiare a punto gli fanno
malissimo ios è lei che mi ha aggredito
questa energia la devi tirare fuori 9
combattere i biscotti di hostel oppure
detto famosa allenano salera per lei tu
non te vojo
vuoi mangiare i biscotti uno che si
mangia un pacco di biscotti adesso
l'avresti fatto spari io se vuoi posso
farti diventare un alice ma mi posso
magnetico no no è meraviglioso questi
sono anche tutti un flash infinito
tratti di cosa meravigliosa cagliari da
luci racconto io di biscotti sotto aver
palloni e lei ma se non può guidare 6
lievitando vecchie tu ascolti
sopravvivano un po di trasformismo che
poi questi moniti mette dentro al cose
se li mangia dopo che le aspetta le
parti di bagno dopo passo un po dire ha
scommesso dire beh ma non le triestine
motivati e lo sto vedendo puoi fare il
sorriso vuoi diventare di treno come tuo
fratello sia maestro si 120 questo qui è
passato adesso siamo appena tornati in
dub che siamo andati alla all'hangar
bicocca
adesso mangiando il pollo di giannasi vi
prego conoscermi non ce la faccio musica
[Musica]
ci vedremo a questi stati in spiaggia
ragazzi no vero io la fabbrica
mangione un altro no mangiati uno dei
tuoi no l'altro mantra ti mai mangiati
l'altro situazione attuale noi siamo i
sabotatori del san valentino e adesso
sta mandando a sabotare il san valentino
per le se riusciamo a convincere già dai
sotto le volte che in questo giro
andiamo a morandi esatto chi vota di
andare a disturbare il san valentino
delle scelte
ora a 2 dal 2 contro 1 andiamo se
compariamo così dal nulla ma che figura
noi lo sappiamo tutti pensano che tu hai
prenotato per questa lucchi come pezza
come stavo mi danno a sabotare san
valentino giro la macchina e un attimo
ragazzi scusate ma senza scusa le quali
ieri a bene lei è morto lì vi faccio ok
ma scendiamo noi scendiamo noi veramente
ci vediamo dopo ragazzi
ok siamo giunti davanti al ristorante in
cui il nostro piccioncino piccione già
adesso faremo finta di aver mangiato a
30 secondi da qui pur di vedere questa
scena mirabolante scopi la deroga certo
anche perché dovrà montare comunque
eravamo in giro si con abbia un
capolavoro e questa festa di me tutto
per cambiare così come dobbiamo
disturbare chi sia la sta vivendo da
vero piccioncini
eccola mi ha scioccato ma mi sa che la
tu
e va bene vi lasciamo con questo
bellissimo san valentino spero che
quello stile passando quelle persone che
mi ha nel miglior modo possibile
[Musica]
dopo l'esperienza con alice dopo
l'esperienza con lui sono tornato a casa
e mi aspetta un parco un parco c'è un
pacco da scartare due ragazzi che hanno
scritto su una mille questi sono
intrufolati davanti a piazza di milano
volto a trovare vita avanti 69
pesantissimo permettermelo sala quadrata
io sia acuti allora io queste persone
bolle odio perché l'ho regalato una cosa
che mi hanno promesso che non avrei mai
avuto ma in realtà un po le amo perché
mi hanno regalato una cosa che sta per
risolvere per sempre una delle cose che
odio più di voi quando venite a casa mia
cos'è una cosa che odio di voi a parte
nostra presenza è io da solo un posto
risponde che odino e vedete troppo caffè
tutte pazze sono impazziti più grandi 18
bello ho saputo da capire le tue ieri
hai lottato con lui per mangiare dei
biscotti che vuol dire lottato col
proveniente avevo un certo languorino
così si stava la magia biscotti e quello
che è quella strappa di mano ecco tu sai
una cosa
questi pubblico e lanciare no come no
certo questi sono i miei biscotti a me
va bene che tu fai quello che vuoi con i
tuoi biscotti ma con i miei p 7 io
decido cosa fare con i miei biscotti non
tu che ti aspetti fino a domani
è una notizia per tutti quanti voi
ragazzi una bella notizia stupenda ma
dovete aspettare domani ve lo dirò mie
impressioni di zloty 80 campionamento
avrei un posto dove tu potresti metterla
ma non voglio essere forte ecco se
volete una sandra già da mettere in quel
posto
io vorrei vitella nell'ufficio però
troviamo e clienti ma abbiamo più casa
non entrati più se poi bussate non vi
apro il primo caffè intanto una palla
linea
rientrano no no ragazza che commozione
avere il caffè che commozione per me è
non avere fretta guardate che cosa c'era
di fondo è pulito no no no ecco linfa
del caffè facciamo un cin
ma fa anche la cioccolata o cose così
questa mattina il mio amico di
cioccolata un discorso discorso ragazzi
che questo sia il primo regalo di molti
che entreranno all'interno del nostro
ufficio che arriverà a brevissimo
questa mi portò ventina se qualcuno
vuole regalarci anche un corso che casa
l'acqua un filtro per l'acqua
distributori d'acqua
noi siamo qui uil hanno gradisce anche
molto le scarpe numero 30 sella sainato
la sede col buco che origina anche gli
atti che fai bisogno di dire da ben
vedere comunque a parte gli scherzi
ragazzi preparatevi perché veramente
domani vita non ha notizia una settimana
di esperienza che vi cambierà dentro e
fuori
non aggiungo altro ma se avete mandato a
roma no a cassano video
e il prossimo episodio ottavo giorno ce
l'abbiamo fatta una settimana intera
passata senza zucchero senza farine
raffinate senza alcol e finalmente di
farlo
l'assaggio non ci posso credere
sentiamo quali sono vera felicità